[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
like Indiana Jones with three how's the
damn good movie though huh removi hey
movie tquan hey so Steve's not going to
twitch don't click it right now no they
wanted you to move your camp sorry
Ashton tails but Steve Lakes our bottom
right
just talking about how your face blocks
the map but whatever
what else thought what up dungeon boys
is it is it twitching there we go
garnet well how do you kill someone when
they die just top top X don't hold it
down there you go tap X yeah I mean
fairy sometimes wherever you think just
you tell us and just tell us when I hope
it won't bother you well no worries it's
kind of fine over it but so maybe there
what might be one T names there people
already died we gonna eject
I'll Griffin sitting on the toilet we're
way to like right now all right
yeah so you guys probably know this but
just like three basics you need you want
like a helmet a chess piece but and it
back in the backpack yeah yeah then
there's levels where'd you guys go we
got turn around Steve I'm talking drag
there there you go okay
do your left little Steve turn left
right there ran into opposite Beach okay
you got the other beach um yeah yeah
straight across the water the back line
oh sorry Steve see if there's anything
over there
we'll come meet you after we'll go over
here and sit there stuff
oh [ __ ] I'm all by myself huh
don't what do you mean I don't know you
don't apart uh big Matt Steve no I don't
know anything yeah bipolar yeah you do a
lot you know how to do that you know how
to do that you've got out of you it is
precipice circle oh okay Steve's in the
circle so we're good so what does go
yeah combat pants or the guns man and
then when it comes to like bandages
first aids or 35% 12-gauge damn like a
smoke grenade there's a scar over here
if anybody wants me oh yeah where are
you I'm good it's like open warehouse
yeah I'm coming Yeah right there
it's in the left corner corner I don't
see any other side you micro uzi stock
level to back back up here - I'll take
it
if you less pikachu's up there now you
can get it take it Oh God all right see
that's why we're gonna have to kick
Pikachu soon I'm kidding you're a good
peach extended mag pistol isn't there
anything else in here so tall house a
backpack I literally got nothing good
here I got the scar and I said I'll get
this just quick draw painkiller oh I got
police vest hell yeah
I dropped this why I should head towards
where you guys are
we're gonna come to you in a minute
we're just giving stop all right up here
and Pikachu there's a m16 if you want to
assault rifle okay you just say no
Pikachu
yeah all right well I'm coming up there
I'll grab some of that stuff I could use
the best what should I do
waiting this little hug for you guys
this little [ __ ] probably got an
airplane drop yeah yeah it might be out
in the water so it might be worth
getting um there's a police vest level
one in here if you guys want it we're a
little far away but let me get this now
where's that where's that vest you said
well it's where I'm the bomb no no no no
I'm talking to I'm talking to dirty I'm
talking to her tea rat and burning and
there's a little flu shots come up here
yeah oh is that you yeah how's me my bad
Oh Pikachu
there's a little nest right here there's
a little one of us downstairs if anybody
doesn't have one
okay cool there's a bit of vertical grip
for your scar right there too there's
one down here I think it was in this
room all right right here right here
backpack anomaly okay I'm gonna drop a
ammo for the scar
let's Pikachu milk it - bro no I don't I
don't need good there's thirty rounds
right here on the girl cue ball thank
you
thank you all right um you go - should
we go get yeah let's go to Steve yeah on
the other side of the beach here just
wait on the shore yeah that's all yeah
boat over here oh yeah whoa classy
I'm coming dirty Pikachu you better be
behind me yeah yeah and then if you put
your guns away you can run faster yeah I
did I did how do you treat it to your to
yours so you can see your character like
that remembered
oh right bumpers plus you're on left
trigger press left trigger again just
tap it tap love trigger yeah there you
go tap it again it's our beat yeah RBZ
switched from first to third person I
love what could have been now you're
looking down your gun and I could tell
you may want to like step in the water a
little bit tonight bananas doing it to
you yeah maybe just because in that open
Beach a lot of people can see you from
there yeah I'm in the water I don't come
more coming those boat just don't drown
okay come on Pikachu
get in the boat they can't shoot from
the boat though can you you can't you
click that left trigger but the water
sprays a face you can't see [ __ ] I don't
know it just it doesn't when I'm zoomed
in on my gun you guys know where I am
I'm trying to get I see words stay by
that show oh yeah okay pick you up honor
you're good here we come okay sub banana
Steve and then employees on chat y'see
why is Ben here
can I get in the boat yeah yeah actually
Ben oh yeah yeah all right cool mob
alright squad I'm so tempted to shoot
Pikachu from here look at this I just
said it's tempting anyway
no you do it
let's figure I told you I can't do it
are you just click anyone that's why the
press wide equip your car there you go
now the trigger all right
how about you point towards someone else
other than us to the enemy there's no
enemy you know you never know dude you
never know the veering away from this
city because people probably went there
for sure how we do it we do the right
objective or what yeah you enter 69
alive
it's gonna be fun when Griffin gets on
your own yeah for sure
Frank's office but then Frank said he
was too tired to play all of a sudden he
said he's home will you pay attention to
the game didn't start looking at your
phone I was checking my texts that was
hypocritical you just looked at your
phone
I like glanced at a glance - well that's
what I was doing I had two texts we're
still alive huh alive so he could check
the map see see where he's going Steve
he's got his thing marked it might be
sketchy though I don't know if people
are gonna be here but we'll see you know
do you think they see us a mile away the
pat-down sniper you can get around okay
I try to get out
he's helping thanks buddy [ __ ] all right
let's go
I'm their dad got that for I got a
painkiller I got a painkiller no don't
take those yet take the first day then
you 100% okay I don't where in front of
us right there with the airhorn tower or
whatever they are they're snipers yeah
yeah what should we do what do we do
what should we do
I don't know talk to you guys
Erik's watching the feed all right uh I
think it's better - how close are they
come on it doesn't work that way doesn't
work that way they should have four - oh
they're gonna four also yeah they might
know how to play the game better that's
the thing you don't worry myself as bait
for us we could take their car and run
away and if you could take the car yeah
that's a smart thing to do
that's smart let's do that okay this is
like it's alright you guys late over
here now this is crazy
this isn't it it's a check oh oh [ __ ]
this year on your day he's by himself
he's one down once back behind you right
there
oh my god
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
I'm sorry I got em right Griffin he's up
in the hills
oh I know
[Laughter]
I got your buddy yeah one do it to yours
it kept like going off your okay where's
this guy shooting ad up on the hill or
up there he's on the hill yeah long ago
I had a lunch okay
oh [ __ ] Frank's here what's up Frankie
Frank oh yeah
I'm Eddie Griffin - 80 on the okay I'll
give you some bandages
Steve Oh am I hurt no you use them -
didn't use them yeah you're I'll take
that stuff in there there's stuff in
there get that backpack there Steve I'm
dropping these okay
okay I'll catch up with those and then
uh some press starts with the ain't and
after you bandage all the way up to that
75% use the painkiller okay right bumper
right bumper right no right again right
again right bumper I am look okay right
again right bumper yeah their news I say
yeah there you go
okay okay that's good yeah behind you
behind you it's on the ground no don't
use the paper you wait till you go all
the way up LA when cancel cancel I got
it
I got another one alright okay how you
guys doing on em huh I don't know man
I'll tell you I'm not doing great at all
are you dad that's the dirt okay now so
make sure if you haven't make sure if
you have an auto rifle you have you
press the left down d-pad to make it
hurts on full auto okay what do we do
about this ground the hill man he knows
we're here
I think he ran away okay we still are
you done no I'm dead dude I'm gonna I'm
gonna yeah press X I think yeah I
picture you want some of our health
nine-millimeter mo whoo did we show that
last guy only think I got someone I
think I got at least one if not two I
know I hit it I hit a couple guys and
the guy had a shot okay I hit that last
guy bad but then somebody else had the
guy ran away so what we do here man I
was just waiting for a bigger treat
advantage oh okay BB one another energy
energy fast nothing it's cool don't use
it on me
yeah that's about I got it comes all
right I think you guys are nice I want
to get his frag grenade oh you guys hey
you're out of the zone you guys got to
get to the zone you're a little loud of
it oh I was paying attention that's you
guys gotta get to the zone okay let's
get the Jeep then huh yeah take that
first aid you gotta pop it before you
move I'll get in the back I can drive if
you want me to you under Steve no no no
I don't know and then pop pop that pain
pills Pete you what's that all right
there you go you're good you're pretty
close okay all right guys good luck
you want to jump in after this one and
then do one with the boys now this is so
fun
haha Frank is I'm sorry I didn't mean to
laugh at you that was no it was funny it
was just funny someone watching you for
like five minutes I was dying for so and
you're just like I think that I don't
know it it's got a rush you know I mean
sometimes yes if I can make those plays
that's what this one's about oh they're
going out of woods or buildings on the
whatever you want man
what is he looking - [ __ ] go in the
woods yeah oh there's a [ __ ] might be
someone up here but there's someone
where get out get out get out get out go
help your boy to help dirty I'm just
getting out right here cuz there's like
Chinese tagging on that can you no no
you can't take there's some vest same do
you want to jump in next with the boys
and try it yes okay I'm gonna let dirty
play with you guys cuz he's a good
leader so I'll watch your [ __ ] back
y'all you're good you're good you play
it you play with the boys
and there's an Uzi there yeah let me get
that is I'm just kiddin there's also
holster the way to spectate though if
I'm in the party probably not is the
master or can you have more people
should we get in the zone
oh yeah but we still got a minute before
it goes yeah let's get back this next
own is deadly though
well let me get in here my Frank left
anyway he was playing another game
you know what I'll do a liquor if you
can get in here just drip finish and
play okay yeah let's get the real bling
oh [ __ ] I got kicked this is where
everybody in the plane came out like we
just got a pic a building in camp like
you guys did that one time
okay you guys want this whole building
right here no no no we're cool
take this yeah yeah yeah you didn't
never probably like preventing seen by
everybody it's done so not only did you
probably drop here from the plane this
place has been looted already yeah yeah
well I see you know right here at 120
there's some weapon down here it's like
a machete it's a sickle Steve there's a
guy out the window just just watch the
windows bro there's a guy out there
there's a guy up you don't want around
man yeah this building wasn't good get
on your bellies get on your bellies
switch to your switch to your other gun
dude you don't want to use those who's
why cuz the other guns better really all
right we'll do what you want do it oh no
it's a shotgun I thought you had a rifle
shotguns good for close ranges aw dude
if they come through the door it's one
hit yeah and then make sure you load it
hold action I don't want to try a
different building oh no no there's
there I'm like there's gonna be
everybody this is a shotgun how do I do
that
press Y there you go now hold X whole -
make sure it's loaded oh he's at 310 at
the front door he came through through
okay Oh like kind or he might be at the
left window of the house
oh man like there's 23 people live in
they're all gonna be in this city Oh
[Music]
goddamn it do you wanna switch control I
forgot you're in that corner with you
yeah yeah you can't move you just got to
push the X and then sit still the only
thing you can't move is your camera all
right let me let me do it again here
I'll start it I'm gonna party I'll I'll
do one more until Griffon shows up you
just want Griffon all back out you guys
- you're good leader dirty so you can
help him
huh I pika cheeks get in here I was on
my own but you guys are doing that hello
chat room I'm actually looking at the
chat hey you should read chat again
ok ok
where are we guys look how far you're
putting up pictures Pikachu
I listen to dirty has a Nigerian loaded
their emotes dog time 25 seconds look at
all these people
oh you like punch people right here yeah
how do you punch this is a nightmare
already follow dirty-ice Eric if you
pull up your map do you know how to do
that
I call it um the old xbox got it got it
got it got it okay
where we going to mark the spot we're
gonna try there again since last time
yellow so I'll let you guys know when we
jump will probably jump right here kinda
I have to make my last game cuz the
servers are going down at 1/4 1/2 an
hour that's subtle
Battlefront aim your camera view horizon
turn around completely around Steve I'm
okay I'm in I'm in the I'm on the shore
okay I'm coming
how do you get on the boat I can't get
on the boat if you guys go in this house
we're here there's a motorcycle helmets
and motorcycle helmets no you do
armor okay oh wait I just ran to buy
something there Steve there's an ak-47
oh wait what is this I'm not gonna
scream mom I'm going to unplug I'm going
to turn it off yeah yeah I'll close the
thing the thing okay I got some new
pants everybody want some pants
okay I'm going upstairs just where I'm
at oh I heard I heard some [ __ ] I'm on
I'm on a roof what is this oh I got a
motorcycle oh man
alright I closed the door I should be
good I ain't gonna get it why can't why
can't you jump off the roof you might
hurt you usually can't now just follow
the icons man oh I found the gun guys I
don't have any [ __ ] bullets sorry
please explain to me the point of that
oh look I got to pick up the ammo that's
right next to it what kind of gun is it
there was no ammo next to it fine
someone took it already yes I gotta
manage the garden I got a backpack guys
just came running in the room with gut
guns blazing I don't have any ammo
what kind of gun is it it's I don't even
know how do I see what kind of gun it is
wait what if you aim it I ain't no fresh
start start Oh
they'll say on the right side okay
r18 nine five doctors yes you know we
get to the restricted area you know what
I don't appreciate these [ __ ] people
my chat going light they're even worse
at this game people I just got a gas can
I have a lot of gas man what's that
shoot seems pointless okay and you don't
want that [ __ ] how do you get rid of it
can't you set people on fire [ __ ] saw
set people on fire
there's I don't have any bullets okay
I'm useless to us right now not to see
it I think yeah I got I got I have three
gas cans Hey okay when we need gas later
Craig you're gonna be like oh I'm not
even playing with you I can tell you
right now you Steve I just switched
another to another backpack wait here's
some [ __ ] you were is that okay I have a
flash ha ha I have a bandage holographic
sight the [ __ ] does that do I still
don't know who's coming you're [ __ ]
me I don't want to switch to a beanie
well there we go red dot sight okay what
is this bandage what do you mean I still
don't have a brother with bullets in it
a Pikachu oh you guys Karen
yeah I'm gonna get a vehicle and then
Pikachu's gonna come pick you guys up
three seat hopefully right there that's
the where I'm right with you Steve [ __ ]
I'm running towards it yeah this is
crazy oh there's a bug we get into can
we get in this truck how about this
truck we got we got three vehicles over
here I can't run why don't you see them
hey why don't we just take the buggy and
then the sidecar motorcycle oh my god
got the right thing and Eric you got it
you got to put your ammo in it by
holding ax all right guys here comes the
blue here comes the vehicles
Pikachu watch out
[Music]
[Laughter]
if you have bandages all we have a first
day to use we gotta go I think Steve
[Laughter]
we're gonna dug through too far in the
blue that's hurting yeah you gotta do
one more we gotta do one more watch them
I want to see press ain't respecting hey
press a to spectate cuz the twitch
because you can watch them play oh my
gosh do a flip off this [ __ ] driver
Oh bumper coke so us its funding okay I
don't know I don't know were you pushing
it were you moving it or no it was just
moving they give my beer controller Dean
you switch with my one of my controllers
let's go in yeah everybody's like
Griffin is a sniper I did not mean to
kill Steve I don't know friendly fire
along
[Music]
I'm trying to get to the my zone yeah I
don't know what's going on all right
dirty what do we do okay where are we
going now just listen to dirty I think
we went too far away
dirty dirty I was muted house me some
more in the middle okay yeah let's go
I'm not playing but I'd say yes I always
try to go middle see okay so we I know
I'm tell you what we're gonna go here
because it's pretty close to the plane
and hopefully can make it down so when
you guys jump your best bet is to look
at the compass up above you and make
that arrow line up with my dad you got
you got you guys got you jump right now
and then lag out you yeah yeah yeah I
see it I see it now the farther you look
up at the skyline so then your float
farther and if you want to dive down and
you know you just look down at the
ground and dive and you have our to your
left right there
uh-huh-huh okay i'm way off building
okay oh I don't see where you guys are
I'm running toward Steve do don't don't
come C to play area okay I'm trying
there's no houses over here guys Pikachu
right Steve check in an outhouse looking
for someone - I'm coming and there's a
rifle here - I guess shot at my game
[ __ ]
nice try and come to me wait why - run
why can't I run my guys going so pick it
up I'm coming look dude I got a military
vest level three okay I'm at the house
with you guys there's a backpack in the
house I was
this is stressful [ __ ] I know does
everybody yeah no oh cool I got Punk'd
glasses thanks if you guys come to me
there's a police vest right here where
oh where is the interstate I here Steve
yeah
I see it there you go bud thank you
buddy
come upstairs hey what happens we're in
the red zone where's your building how
the hell'd you get okay here we go okay
[ __ ] me
which building are you oh there's
something in here Arthur
Oh give me this ammo oh this is a
[ __ ] load I'll come and drop the ammo
form Pikachu cuz that's for that gun
yours takes seven points something how
do you drop on a [ __ ] ammo highlight
over and plus why to drop at all no Erik
we were upstairs again
I was following Steve I get this right
I'm looking out the windows what are
they at where they at your pass I think
no he's down there
you got the gun Griffin yeah
I got it I think we're caught up I'm
gonna check this house up here where we
got this is this is nerve wracking I'm
like nervous [ __ ]
Oh somebody said I should drop the
shotgun how the [ __ ] do you drop the
shot how do you you go to you go to
start button and then you can put also
the shotguns not bad for close range
dude I don't know all right all right I
like it
are we going down said yeah that double
barrel is very strong but how do you let
me go
oh [ __ ] red zone red zone red zone what
are we doing man you guys now you guys
are pretty much clear we can start
running oh we weren't okay we follow and
dirty I say yes no white man like the
map is stupid like you're running like
we're running straight you know what I
mean yeah why don't I have a shirt on
[Laughter]
across the field I'm gonna get this car
I'm scared I'm coming
[Laughter]
but don't talk about those people if
they were over here in the car in the
car any help
yeah just cuz you're easier targets it's
really blast people out of cars [ __ ]
a by the way the markets damaged oh but
you did you ain't taking me alright we
can move here if you want
where do you see those be like oh
they're gone now
hey there's Annie came here arrest s12
that's a semi-auto shotgun you want this
or do I want wait I think I want this
better
I want the m16 better right yeah m60 is
pretty good but it's semi-auto
but it's very good at long range hey
there's some backyards up here if you
know that one well there's some genius
there's some damage does somebody want
some skinny jeans everyone have all
their day oh there's a tommy gun down
here that might be good here we switch
to another backpack level two now's my
opportunity there's three levels it just
increases space that you can hold stuff
okay so you need a helmet the issue
let's see yeah Oh your oh my god I have
no bullets in my gun oh my god I know I
didn't notice I was trying to practice
shooting for a song at this tree are we
getting back in our car and getting the
[ __ ] out of here there's one more
building only this one okay I'm gonna
grab the car we're ready to go for a
quick escape I'm good
who has the aka there's a there's a and
there's a helmet in here and there's a
kmo in here too where oh there's another
a cane I'm bringing the car around
there's someone right here where my
scarring
take the helmet Steve take the helmet
yeah right there on the ground if you
don't got one I think I had God tell me
go I have I think you already have
yeah there's a m4 in here guys Steve :
yeah trade out that shotgun for this
guns juice which one it's in this back
room right here yeah
oh this one I don't know if you're it I
can drop you some if you want
what's your other gun now yeah
then will you trade it no trade out your
shotgun for that yeah
are we following that that thing again
that this is why we can't attack speed
we're going offroad and [ __ ] it see that
bridge up there that's what we're we
gotta stay to the left of those rocks
okay this is we're gonna be careful a
lot of people just like a motto here we
go [ __ ]
stops what stops moving
do you I'm gonna drop your first day you
can't just stay in the car don't peek
out when you jumped out of the car
barricade the bridge pull all the way up
to that that debris up there okay
the left we're not to take her yeah
they're just gonna gun us down take your
help
hey drive the car go walking dead I'm
gonna be deep hey let Steve heal first
let Steve feel for right looks like
looks like they're scared and they're
driving from us we'll just wait for
Steven we're good to go
keep looking hey just keep driving just
keep driving I just ran over someone I
think or turn left whatever which way
you want to go yeah okay now what all
right now it's up to you guys where we
want to go I don't know keep going isn't
there better car there's a better car
right there broken down that's broken
down let's break it down
oh yeah now let's go see if there's
anything over here I need some I got I
think I got another one yeah I'm gonna
use it when I get out oh my god yes he
needs a bandage of off-road off-road
your left and this is the army base we
got to be careful Oh No there here we go
and then by Arthur Murray
oh my wanted let me it won't let me use
it so when you're at 75% you can only
use pills or drinks to get you to 100
okay well I'm getting back in the
vehicle how do you use you get to press
X then you go to your thing yeah you
pause it and then you push RB to switch
over to that that category
and then you scroll down on what you
want to use so bandages give you like
nine like maybe give you like 58% health
or something I have an energy drink do I
use my energy drink no don't use that
cuz your full health right now
hmm Pikachu play the game I am you know
you're on chat I know what you're doing
I'm not to go back to where we came from
no no we're like we oh you know what we
have to get back into the circle guys I
know but it's moving to all of your map
yeah yeah yeah that's when it will start
moving Hey okay where is this I can't
look at the map actually let along
Direction let me give Steve ammo before
we leave because do you have no ammo
that's why I wanted to get that off okay
we're not a dirty draw - he knows where
to go yeah right here Steve we have 57
seconds okay I got it
load make sure you load it Steve are we
going the right way I think we're going
away yeah we're gonna have to go down a
hill if you go up there but yeah you're
good Oh careful when you go over the
edge it's pretty fun though huh I don't
know what's in here guides but this is I
mean we can loot it it's in the circle
we just don't know if people are in here
Oh
it's not me
Oh people stay together and shoot
the car just go yeah no they killed us
in a car I know but the cars gonna be
here
where's where's uh Steve I'm right here
go go go go people shot at us
yeah he can tell you dirty can tell you
where to go right dirty just turn left
turn left here you go down the hill
right get back towards the road but
you're gonna want to slow down on where
these it's gonna be a bumpy ride
keep yeah you're good yeah I mean we're
in the circle right now we're just
getting a car to get away from us we got
to be careful remember people are all in
the bridge let's go to these houses
right here Park in the back of it yeah
yeah and usually used wide apart
oh no it's not much keep going they're
sure they're shooting that people that
are trying to cross the bridge careful
careful
get out get out get out this finals and
this final circle is just gonna be chaos
like you hear shots all around us before
okay get in if you go around the right
side pick at you okay good
all right your dad was okay there's a
sniper rifle here I want to pick that up
that thing sucks
horribly I'm gonna heal myself okay
Steve take take it energy drink if you
have one I don't have one okay wait huh
oh that's Pikachu because the safe in
here goes
depending on the next circle we may need
to get less you guys know we're still in
the circle we're still in the circle I
know yeah but we need to get to our
vehicle and we never one answer towards
the door if someone could just wait and
gun is down good if you guys want to do
the vehicle we can stick to these
buildings depending on where the next
circle is it
oh yeah that's like I mean you can trade
it out for your shock and it's better
than that right now maybe it's a really
small round
Oh shh shh so many cards don't shoot get
on the ground
[Laughter]
oh when you're on the ground and you
press L that's great you have like a
really clear view where you gonna shoot
oh yeah
I wonder figured out can we open the
refrigerator in there
I hope someone opens anymore okay what
are we doing hey
there's 22 people all left alive yeah
we're four of them there's 18 okay
awesome motorcycle he's going over the
hill we're in the next circle we're here
a lot of vehicles around here guys but
we don't have to worry about I just pay
attention to our doors I guess maybe the
window stand but there is gonna be
someone moving into this one of these
buildings if you look at the mini-map
takes a lot of buildings around here
yeah I got your I got your three o'clock
dirty dog
all right oh [ __ ] the circle just got
real small
people are still dropping in at this
time yeah I'm going now that's wrong
that's a care package just don't shoot
out windows unless it's a threat Eric if
you want to stay in the bathroom watch
TV you should cover that I know I know
that's what I'm saying I'm trying to
watch the window from yeah not that one
yeah because you has that one I have the
front okay I got these windows yeah I go
right all over the couch yeah Carla the
couch and face the back window package
out the window around watch that window
this one yeah yeah yeah if you can see
it if not if you're more comfortable to
back yo you're fine I just going good
there's a teen alive and we're just
weird you know Thanks I mean this next
this next circle closing in is going to
be me cows
okay we're still in the circle though
for the Wow we're like in the epicenter
of this [ __ ] yeah another thing guys is
if you get in the blue now just sit in a
game it's gonna hurt you a lot like do
like 20% damage one per second something
huge okay so try not to leak blue hit
you will help you guys do this oh my god
okay the blue looks like it's gonna hit
us now we're good look how small can the
[ __ ] thing get oh I can get [ __ ]
on the map yeah if you push up on the
d-pad oh you're saying though if you're
not don't worry about it you're in good
shape
alright now the next circle is behind us
hole let's chill here
we got a minute and a half but we don't
want to get out because there's gonna be
a [ __ ] ton of people behind us on this
[Music]
that time I thought I heard okay I'm
ready to blast [ __ ] ten seconds blues
gonna start moving we're gonna go out
this door to my right okay what are you
talking about we're gonna get up quick
it's a quick you know you think it takes
like are you guys ready to get up go
behind me I'm watching your back
whoa watch your 12 o'clock don't go that
way guys
you go this way how do you how do you
climb okay [ __ ] there's guys to our left
hey guys there's a fly Campbell there
was a travesty oh [ __ ] what are you
going on oh you guys did
switch to your a K it's a little more
accurate Pikachu
okay Pikachu shoot in my auto easy
person and put it in first person that
far away
Purcell yeah yeah running you to a
grenade but even to it to your left
another scheme has the nerve number five
I shoulda came with you guys
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]